un sens interdit qui barre l'entrée de
l'école des chaînes cadenassées au gris
le message est clair pas d'école
aujourd'hui pour les élèves de rouvres
et ici il ya trois enseignantes plus une
maîtresse allophones elle vient quelques
jours par semaine s'occupait des enfants
du centre d'accueil pour demandeurs
d'asile qui ne parle pas français
23 enfants intégrer ensuite aux
différentes classes et qui porte à 82 le
nombre d'élèves les enfants du canada
aurait accepté depuis deux ans ou bien
sûr ça change il y en a car il n'y en a
qu'un pas et justement le cade a été
très bien acceptée depuis deux ans par
la population se montent c'est une bonne
intégration qui a été bon on demande
simplement qu'on nous donne les moyens
maintenant de bain de gérer donc les
enfants du cada et nos enfants
et c'est très content at d'état ouvre
ici et du coup ils sont contents aussi
ma fille vient d'arriver à l'école dont
je suis trop content allah pour qu'il
puisse apprend le français très bien la
france m'a dit ça à 100 mais va troquer
sont trop contents pouvait aller aussi
ai je trop content pour les autres
enfants pour que tous puissent suivre
l'école dans de bonnes conditions et à
leur rythme ce que demandent les parents
aujourd'hui c'est l'ouverture d'une 4e
place ça désengorgerait les classes
puisque on passerait d'effectifs à
presque 30 enfants plus que 20 avoir
quatre quatre classes avec moins
d'élèves ça permettra aux maîtresses de
s'occuper de tout le monde correctement
plutôt que de laisser de côté les
enfants du cada en livrant avoir des
cours avec une maîtresse allophones même
lorsqu'ils savent parler français
l'inspecteur d'académie s'est déplacé ce
matin les parents ont obtenu un rendez
vous à l'inspection académique à dijon
ils sont reçus en ce moment même la
suite du mouvement dépendra de cette
entrevue